i i know zoologist
i wouldn't be surprised if you knew one
because i feel like in australia there's
there's a lot more zoologists it's just
because we've got this next-door
neighborhood yeah right because there's
just so much more wildlife over there
you yeah everyone needs to be as you all
are just otherwise how do you know
what's going to kill you every time i've
never been to birmingham
every time every time a snake pops up
it's like someone call a zoologist and
ted is like yeah all right [ __ ] let's
have a look at this yeah you're right
you're right she'll be all right
i'd never met someone who does stuff
with zoos that is sad
what do you mean people who work you've
never met a depressed zoologist people
who like work with animals are always
like the most chill happiest people to
be fair
i would be pretty happy as well if i
could work with animals yeah when you
hear about these like they're always in
australia like yeah we walk on the coast
and they're just like they're like help
coral or some [ __ ] and they're just
always like super happy
like yeah you save the coral
i love it you know what kind of message
will they be presenting if they're like
super simple i want a miserable duology
you know like turns out
planets dying is [ __ ] annoying yeah i
can't do it [ __ ] kangaroos out of my
backyard i don't know i feel like i feel
like you're either like happy that
you're working with animals that you
like to be around right uh because
you've chosen to be in that profession
or i mean like the the only thing i can
think of is people who work with like
venomous animals or something like that
or animals that can put you in danger
and but if that's the case you have to
be someone who's enthusiastic yeah they
love you they [ __ ] love it right
they're like oh don't don't put the
crocodile too hard yeah i'm gonna chuck
it yeah i'm gonna jump on it yeah it's
like it's like those videos of like
those like you know venomous like snake
and spider collectors they're just like
every time they're like all right i just
got a brand new uh tarantula this thing
could kill me in an instant but my god
she's a beauty you know like it's just
like it's so happy to see this like
really uh to be fair a lot of venomous
creatures do look [ __ ] cool yeah
would i want to be around one though
that's your life insurance no uh does
your life insurance cost go up if you
own like a venomous spider or a snake
you might have to maybe like double vac
that [ __ ] you know
there's a snake with like a covered
venom you know like the newest straight
like the delta strain of like the cobra
but wouldn't it be so cool if like and
like you know uh anti-venom just like
work like that or like you know
antidotes for venomous poison it just
works
even if you did you wouldn't get it
because like why would you why would any
normal person need like 100 different
[ __ ] snake
uh
infection venom i don't [ __ ] know
what do we do with that [ __ ] killer
from hunter hunter well you know poison
training no but like what if you're like
going to like a specific like area of
the world that has like because they do
see danger if you go to like uh certain
places that have like really bad uh
mosquitoes or something yeah you get
like right now
so why so why not like people who say
like you know decide like oh i want to
go to the australian outback be like all
right just give me like i don't think
it's that much of a concern well yeah i
feel like i think i feel like you
haven't hear about people dying i feel
like you have more chance of getting hit
in like by a car in the airport than you
do from getting so i feel like we should
ban cars before we sydney airport
that plays a [ __ ] mess it feels like
the dumbest superpower anyone could hope
for yeah it's just it's it's just like
that one guy in like mayhew academy who
has quirks against like every anti-venom
and he's only useful in australia like
everywhere else in the world he's just
useless he's like born in the uk he's
like what [ __ ]
i can't use this at all
yeah exactly yeah yeah i mean you can
you can build up some resistances to
like some venoms i don't know how much
you can build up resistance because i
don't know if there's been any studies
of like anyone who's like tried to build
up enough resistance like take on like a
back black cobra or something like that
yeah um but i don't think you'd need to
yeah it's like alcohol isn't it you just
get more used to it
but it's it's like that's uh
the more you get bitten the more
resistant
i assume if there is like uh something
that
makes i don't know like there's those
ants or something that like make you
really in pain maybe if you just like
what aunt specific like
like like
what if you got bitten by one every
single day surely after a while is you
wouldn't phase you after like 10 years
maybe she wants to try this
well no because like experiments
isn't there that tribe that is like
revolved around putting a glove of
bullet hands on your hands but i think
they do it every day though i think i
don't think yeah they don't do it it's
like it's like a sarah it's like tim
where's my what's my uh
my pharynx
i'm pretty sure it's like a uh thing
that they do during ceremonies it's like
to initiate like a kid into ch
yeah yeah but like from what i can
understand like the people in the tribe
are more resistant to that venom than
other people who have prided that oh
yeah obviously
yeah so i mean i don't know why they
like who who decided that
who decided that they would do that as a
ceremony you know what let's just get a
bunch of [ __ ] answers
you're a man now i want to hear like the
the council meeting of like when they
decided that they were like all right so
so jim's just turned 18 you know he's
he's been he's ready to bear children
he's ready to be a dad um yeah but we
need like a ceremonious thing
some guy's like
maybe just share a beer with him well
it's like yeah that's kind of like what
if we though
hear me out
put his hands
into a fire ant nest genius i i probably
gets it i'm i'm i understand why i mean
you know i'm not here to be like wow
because
think about it
we look at the [ __ ] stars and we're
like oh well turns out i'm i'm angry
what what you know
what what do you mean with like star
signs and stuff you know
the only difference is that we just
agree you talk about like astrology yeah
yeah yeah i'm joking
you're like oh i'm gonna get married
tomorrow apparently yeah oh i thought i
thought i was just like i don't think
angry is a star sign no no no you could
be angry right from the start position
aries
on yeah uh like you know they probably
thought that it had some meaning and it
probably carried some value of course
like i'm sure right here's the thing
we know that like jumping in a cold
bath or something is good for you yeah
we know that because of science like
showers but before if there was no
science backing this up and you were
like connor jump in the math for some
for health reasons i'm like [ __ ] off i'm
not jumping in a cold bath why would i
jump in a cold bear i'm not doing that
it's stupid i mean why would that help
me i wouldn't do it even if i knew that
was hilarious right like you know now
that there is right and so i can
understand why maybe these people have
this notion that like i'm sure
there might even be health benefits to
getting bitten by our heads i don't know
maybe there is we haven't we just
haven't researched it there's so many
things that haven't been researched we
don't know i don't i don't think this is
worth researching personally
what if i told you that like if you like
you know uh inflated your uh your big
toe once a year would help with curing
alzheimer's you're probably like well
[ __ ] i'm not gonna do that but thanks
you know what i mean there's so many
things that can help ex disease or help
stop things right you're like i just i'm
just not going to do that like when
they're like that one paper came out
that one time that was like research
suggests eating no more than five french
fries at a time to lower the risk of
cancer it's like let's be honest i'm
never gonna eat less than five french
fries that's just impractical i'm just
not gonna mcdonald's feel like i don't
care i i i think like at the end of the
day people just don't care
like if they couldn't convince smokers
to stop smoking by like actual
scientific research that proved that it
heavily increases your chance to get
cancer the more you smoke you know if if
they couldn't convince humanity to stop
smoking after that then
then what would like five french fries
like
five like eating less than five french
fries yeah because like the moment
you're like uh yeah you should probably
stop smoking because you know it could
give you every type of lung cancer or
you know just cancer in general there's
just like weird yeah it's kind of cool
like i think that's it but as humans
like we're so [ __ ] at uh recognizing
long-term effects and by long-term in
like more than like a week yeah like
something effect we just don't think
it'll affect us yeah because it's like
oh it's a week away anything could
happen
tomorrow we just we just ignore the fact
that bad stuff can happen to us by doing
it yeah but but yet isn't it so weird
that there's such like a a disposition
between people who are like that where
they're like oh it's happening in like
three days from now that's basically
never gonna happen to people who you
know say believe in things like
astrology where they're like oh in 73 in
years and four days time i'm going to
get hit by a car well [ __ ] i better stop
repairing it
you know like those kinds of like
police-based like systems right like you
know not to like you know not to throw
anyone's belief system under the bus you
can believe whatever the [ __ ] you want
right but like that was one thing i
always had trouble you know coming to
terms with with that kind of stuff right
where it's like it's so up in the air
that it really and it's not backed up by
science in any way as of right now that
it's like
you know how how why would you even
think about something like that whereas
like with smoking for example it's like
well yeah um i had like seven of my
[ __ ] grand you know friends granddads
die because of lung cancer probably due
to smoking so you should you know if
that doesn't convince you
yeah i mean i guess i guess it comes
down to the point where like it's it's
like even now science
as sad as it is science in the in this
day and age isn't always like the
determining factor over whether people
listen to uh
listen to what science says or not
because nowadays it's because science is
the government do and you don't want to
trust the government well i think
science the problem is with science and
you know the this age of like
misinformation and just not knowing what
one is one is a lot of misinformation
out there not knowing which sources to
trust and number two science has just
got so advanced that the normal person
isn't going to be able to follow along
with what science says because the logic
is so past what a normal person would be
able to understand that you might as
well be talking about god or [ __ ] or
[ __ ] stars in the sky because like
you know how am i gonna understand what
the [ __ ] scientists are researching when
it comes to like making mini black holes
in the cern like institute or whatever
like and they're like [ __ ] firing
protons at each other like the [ __ ] do i
know about that yeah you know you know
what i mean that's that's so fuc they're
so far beyond my knowledge of
understanding just sounds like science
fiction it literally sounds like science
fiction you know unfortunately we're a
sucker for a good answer and an easy
solution yeah yeah so especially when
like you know the top researchers and
scientists in the world are like you
know when explaining like how does
gravity work and they're just like we
don't know then they're like ah i told
you
must be jesus yeah you know like just
like because we hate it when we don't
know something
like no matter how significant or
insignificant it is and so when
immediately when we're thrown into that
kind of situation humans are just very
good to be like oh it's magic must be
magic a lot of times we just garner
towards what feels right or what we want
to believe you know it's like we like to
believe that we're all like unbiased
robots who only go with pure facts and
logic but a lot of the times we are very
biased towards our beliefs and it takes
i guess i guess it takes a lot more
effort to unbelieve and unlearn
something than it is to just you know
than it is to
um
learn something fresh or just like build
up your beliefs fresh i'm sure that
happens in like between scientists as
well right like as much as you think
scientists are just like purely like
facts and logic based only no emotion
thrown into whatsoever i'm sure you know
there's been instances where like a
scientist or you know let's say like a
physicist like comes up and be like all
right i've got this new theory yeah
about how the universe was created what
do you think
here's a bunch of theoretical things
that you know we've been researching all
that kind of stuff i'm sure there's been
a couple of scientists who are like
no yeah that sounds dumb as [ __ ] because
i don't like you yeah
that happens a lot right and you know a
lot of scientists also religious a lot
of them you know because there's a lot
of
we don't know a lot of things and also
science isn't about
um having concrete answers it's about
attempting and trying everything and
then proving that there's no other way
yeah it could be anything else right i
think that's the problem is that a lot
of people have this rigid view of
science is like it can only be
science is a hundred percent right all
the time and it's not we're just
eliminating things that we know for sure
it isn't yeah yeah and so a lot of the
time when theories are uh presented or
hypotheses or whatever you know we have
so so many examples of history being
incorrect and yeah we fix it when we
realize it and the problem is is that
a lot of the time that kind of gets
galvanized into being like all right
well look science is wrong sometimes
they get it wrong and it's like no we
never science is never ever presented to
know everything it's we're building the
most it's the most accurate
representation that we have at this
current time we're building up a library
of what we think i think i think like
tim mentioned said it the best way he
said like science adjusts its views
based on what's observed yeah and faith
is the denial of observation so that
belief can be preserved yeah and i'm
like that's pretty much it because it's
like science yeah as you said like
science changes all the [ __ ] time
because we don't know everything in the
world right so it's like so we have to
kind of make compromises for what we now
know which could completely change what
you know like say like 500 years ago
when people legitimately believed that
like the sun rotates around the earth
and not the other way around and then
when they discovered that they were like
well [ __ ] all these sights what have all
these scientists been doing for the past
500 years wasting our time problem is
that we're really bad as like humans of
understanding
stuff we don't know yeah uh you know
because if you'd have back then it would
make total sense that we the sun
revolves around ours because it looks
like it does and yeah we don't have any
other way of even remotely comprehending
that it couldn't revolve around us
but once you find out it's like oh well
of course of course of course we revolve
around it that makes so much sense yeah
so it's really easy to
believe in the
thing that you your makes sense now that
makes most like logical sense in your
brain because like yeah like i said like
i said before like science now has got
to a point where a lot of the more
advanced concepts uh where the normal
person is not going to be able to
comprehend and so at that point you're
going to have your just putting your
faith in a person of authority that
their understanding is good enough that
they can you know take what these
studies say and present that in a manner
which you can understand but at the end
of the day you're still putting a trust
your trust into something that you don't
fully understand yourself